Good morning, Hank, it's Friday.
Couple things. Thing one: in re:your last video,
it is not an anchoring bias to dismiss the opinions of people who don't like The Mountain Goats.
It's just a correct aesthetic judgement.
Hank, there are just facts in this world, like the fact that my Sing-A-Ma-Jig compositions
[plays music]
are excellent, but inferior to Mozart.
And here's another fact: The Mountain Goats are a great band!
And *yes* my voice cracked; I'm angry!
Thing two: Hank, your video on Wednesday reminded me of my favorite kind of bias, the denomination effect.
The denomination effect shows that people are biased towards spending money in small denominations,
like, we're more likely to spend one hundred one dollar bills than we are to spend one one hundred dollar bill.
It's also shown that across the world people are biased towards spending coins
rather than spending paper money.
Although not American pennies of course, because no one spends American pennies
because they're worthless and evil.
You wanna an anchoring bias, Hank, I have an anchoring bias against people who don't hate pennies.
So Hank, you know why I hate pennies: it's because they cost more than a penny to make
and they also don't work as money because they don't facilitate the exchange of goods and services.
Like, try going to a gas station and spending three hundred eighty-three pennies on a gallon of gas.
Lots of countries have eliminated their pennies.
Like, the Netherlands has no pennies
and you know what happened? Nothing.
Inflation didn't go up, charitable contributions
didn't go down. Pennies are useless!
Also if we got rid of the penny it would save the government millions of dollars a year.
It's the kind of thing that you would do
if you were trying to, say, cut the budget
and you were serious about it
instead of just playing political games.
Right, I'm getting distracted by my hatred of pennies.
The denomination effect does not apply to pennies
but it applies to most coins!
Y'know, coins that have value.
Which brings me to the one dollar coin.
Hank, there are like a billion one dollar coins
sitting around the United States
but no one ever uses them
because people like paper money.
But the non-partisan government accountability office recently reported to Congress
that if we eliminated the one dollar bill
and introduced one dollar and two dollar coins
we would save 5.5 billion dollars over the next thirty years.
Billion with a B.
This is for two reasons: First, it costs a lot of money to print one dollar bills.
It now costs 9.6 cents per bill
thanks to the rising price of cotton.
And secondly, the average one dollar bill is only
in circulation for forty months,
whereas the average one dollar coin would be
in circulation for like, thirty years.
And we wouldn't even have to mint any new coins because we already have a billion one dollar coins
that no one is using. We just need to remove the bills
so that people have to use them.
And if we did that people might be slightly inconvenienced for a while,
though they seemed to have gotten used to it
in Canada and Europe.
But aside from saving the federal government
five billion dollars,
the denomination effect tells us that people
would also spend more money!
And consumer spending is the number one driver
of economic growth in America.
In short, Hank, there are a lot of hard choices to make, but the denomination effect reminds us
that there are also some easy choices to make,
and we aren't making them.
Okay Hank, couple other things:
First, Nerdfighters, thank you so much for
continuing to make The Fault in Our Stars
a bestseller on Amazon and Barnes and Noble.
I don't... even know what to say about that, but...
you're made of awesome.
Also I want to thank Nerdfighters
Julie and Martha for making
WillAllPreordersOfTheFaultInOurStarsBeSigned.com,
my favorite website ever!
You'll find a link in the doobly-doo.
It succinctly answers the question
I've been asked hundreds of times this week.
Speaking of which, please don't forget
that *you* are deciding
which color sharpie I will use to sign these books!
Nerdfighters, this is serious business. There is a link in the doobly-doo to a poll in your pants
-- is not something people say about serious business.
No really, I do want to get the color right, so vote.
Oh, and don't forget to read the first six chapters of
The Great Gatsby by Wednesday!
I know you don't come on YouTube for homework
but you just got some!
Hank, I'll see you on Monday.